les efforts diplomatiques de la
communauté internationale y compris deux
moscou reste pour l'heure sans effet la
meilleure poutine s'est d'ailleurs
exprimé sur le sujet à l'occasion d'une
interview diffusée sur une des chaînes
du service public russe il expliquait
que ce conflit était un véritable crève
coeur pour la russie qui se sont aussi
proches de l'azerbaïdjan que de
l'arménie et où vivent de très nombreux
ressortissants de ces deux pays
proposent d'écouter son intervention à
cause de ce match tout comme vous le
savez l'arménie est membre de
l'organisation du traité de sécurité
collective
nous avons certaines obligations envers
l'arménie en vertu de ce traité
mais les hostilités à notre grand regret
se poursuivent toujours
et cela ne se passe pas en territoire
arménien quant au respect par la russie
de ses obligations en vertu de ce traité
nous les avons toujours remplies nous
les remplissons et nous continuerons de
les remplir
comme vous le savez les ide en contact
permanent avec le premier ministre
arménien et les dirigeants arméniens
note aucun doute quant au respect par la
russie de ses obligations dans le cadre
du traité on l'a entendu le président
russe a évoqué l'organisation du traité
de sécurité collective qui lie entre
autres la russie et l'arménie
celui ci inclut une clause de solidarité
dans le cas d'une attaque extérieure
mais tant que le conflit ne concerne que
le haut karabagh et pas l'arménie en
elle-même alors le traité ne s'applique
pas
reste donc la diplomatie vladmir poutine
s'est par exemple entretenu dans la
journée avec le président azerbaïdjanais
ilham aliyev le dialogue entre les
belligérants et le rôle d'un médiateur
comme celui de la russie reste donc pour
l'heure le meilleur espoir de voir
cesser les combats